bonsoir devant saison merci d'être avec
nous l'union européenne qui rejette donc
le résultat de l'élection et annonce des
sanctions
cette décision des vingt-sept était-elle
prévisible que pouvait-il faire
autrement je crois que oui c'est cette
réaction était prévisible
elle est d'ailleurs relativement
relativement prudente parce que la
situation et est assez difficile à
saisir et elle est très évolutive à
minsk et en biélorussie en général le
plus important c'est que le conseil
européen a réaffirmé que c'était 2 à la
population de l'est la russie de trouver
les voies et moyens conduisant une
solution politique
on a une crise politique très importante
puisque le dimanche 9 août
le président peut hâter a été réélu et
dit qu'il a été réélu à 80 % des voix et
une majorité de la population
apparemment le compte est donc ce n'est
pas un mécontentement de la population
biélorusse ce qui aurait des motifs
en effet le manifester c'est la
contestation de l'élection du dimanche 9
qui aurait fait l'objet d'un certain
nombre de manipulations et la servante
de tricherie et donc l'union européenne
marquent sa solidarité avec la
population biélorusse qui demande
l'organisation de nouvelles élections
qui demande la libération des
prisonniers politiques c'est un point
important qui demandent l'arrêt des
violences et c'est très important à un
moment où le président biélorusse vient
de redemander à sa police de faire
cesser toutes les manifestations et on
peut être très inquiet sur la façon dont
cela se fera et puis en effet l'union
européenne a pris également deux mesures
concrètes qui consiste à réorienter vers
la société civile les flux dead qui
existe entre l'union européenne et la
biélorussie et puis deuxièmement de
préparer
une liste de personnalités qui sont
liées aux fraudes électorales ou qui
sont liées à la violence de la
répression
et ces personnalités pour l'objet donc
de sanctions ciblées probablement
interdiction de détenir des comptes en
banque les uns et impossibilité
d'obtenir des visas
alors cette décision est ce que
finalement ça fait avancer les choses
pour les biélorusses
on peut penser que oui en tout cas
j'espère que oui parce que sinon ça
serait assez grave pour est gras oui
parce que ça encourage naturellement au
dialogue c'est le message principal est
il faut que s'instaure un dialogue entre
toutes les parties prenantes de la
société biélorusse
les gens qui sont au pouvoir
actuellement les gens qui contestent ce
pouvoir les gens qui en prison en exil
représente quelque chose sur le plan
politique et il faut que ce dialogue
s'instaure donc je pense que la décision
prise par le conseil européen petit et
des deuxièmement les sanctions
individuelles qui sont pas encore prises
sur le principe on est décidé
la liste va être élaboré dans les
prochains jours on peut penser que
certains responsables des services de
force n'ont pas très envie d'être sur
cette liste est actuellement la question
est de savoir jusqu'à quel point les
responsables des services de force sont
loyaux au régime au régime en place
on entend des échos tout à fait
différent mais en effet si le président
loukachenko a d'ores et déjà resté à
d'ores et déjà pris la décision de faire
dans le tout répressif
ce qu'a fait le conseil européen
aujourd'hui ne servira pas à grand chose
à ce moment là on aura peut-être un
pourrissement de la situation
on aura peut-être le président
loukachenko qui restera au pouvoir pour
quelques semaines quelques mois quelques
années et astor cette hypothèse
malheureusement l'économie de
biélorussie qui continuera à péricliter
et les problèmes
sociaux les palmes politique qui
s'aggrave au alors quelles solutions
possibles pour sortir de la crise à
présent la solution la pie ix serait que
le président de la biélorussie qui a
massé des troupes aux frontières de la
lituanie alors qu'il est lui même menacé
d'une intervention extérieure provoque
un incident aux frontières de la
lituanie provoque un incident pour
peut-être demander à faire jouer les
clauses de l'organisation du traité de
sécurité collective qui le lie à la
russie et à quatre autres pays de
l'ancienne union soviétique pour obtenir
une forme de solidarité militaire
j'espère qu'on n'en arrivera pas là et
j'espère que la plateforme pour le
dialogue citoyens pour organiser les
voies et moyens d'une nouvelle élection
pourra s'installer et pourra retrouver
une solution pacifique à la crise
politique actuelle qui est une crise est
une crise sérieuse
évidemment il ya d'autres hypothèses qui
sont qui sont également envisageables
comme le départ spontané du président le
coach enhco mais c'est évidemment peu
probable puisque le connaissant et
voyant les propos qu'il tient il est
probable qu'il ne peut pas partir a pas
de son plein gré et que même contraint
et forcé il résistera jusqu'à la
dernière limite
merci cob blanchemaison je rappelle que
vous êtes expert en relations
internationales merci à vous